so if someone watching this at home
wants to help
make the case for cash relief because i
know there are there's so many people
that
uh want to see this happen um and there
are different things you can do you can
the traditional thing is like write your
member of congress uh
no um they can certainly support
humanity forward
uh but like do you when someone asks you
this question like where do you send
them
yeah i mean it there's some there's
certainly more options now
and i guess one of the questions i ask
is like you know
what is it that you want to do in
not only like what's available but even
like what skill sets do you have
that you could even create something new
like what would be
even like an enjoyable thing like a fun
thing for you to do
um you know maybe you'd like to write um
something maybe you'd like to you know
as for like a you know submit it to your
local paper or
maybe like to write to your members of
congress or maybe you'd like to
start up a a podcast or maybe you
already have a podcast and like let's do
like a topic about
basic income or something along those
lines like you know there's various
things that people can do
and certainly you know getting money to
um as funding for humanity forward
is uh you know a great way to go about
that now but uh and also
i really like scottsdale.com no need to
feel restricted
or scott sanders.com but also you know
income movement
which is at incomemovement.com is doing
a lot of great stuff grassroots
organizing people can
you know be involved there
that's uh that's great and also we've
got the
you know the basic income march is
coming up here in september
and um that's really exciting to see
happen again
um hopefully there again be even more
people
um this time than the previous times and
that could show even more movement so
people can hey if you've
if you um if there's already something
scheduled
um and a march in your place then in
your in your area then
you know please attend it and if there
isn't then
please be that person that you know sets
it up and
um helps uh organize that so there's
there's definitely things that that
people can do that um
you know didn't really exist years ago
so you've seen
basic income grow from this marginal uh
thing no one had heard of back in 2014
let's call it in 15
16 and now in 2021 it appeals to a lot
of people like we're this close i mean
it feels like that to me
you know we're sending out checks to
tens of millions of people it's like why
don't we just keep on doing it
uh you know it has grown the majority of
americans are for it
i can't tell you just walking around
really anywhere
people recognize me and uh are excited
to see me and
and the rest of it and one of the things
they'll always say to me is they'll say
love ubi
don't be like that and it happens to me
frequently enough where i guarantee that
these people are not hanging out on
forums
or uh you know uh that like they're not
they don't strike me as activists and so
it seems like there's a ton of energy
and one of my projects now is to try and
figure out how to both grow that energy
and also
translate it into action and policy so
we have humanity foreign on the lobbying
side
we have people who can do things like
participate in the basic income march
uh and and organize locally
and so now my efforts are going to go
towards trying to make it so that our
government's actually more responsive
to the will of the people because that
connection has unfortunately
been breaking down for quite some time
there's so much
that can happen at the at the local
level that um
that that i don't think enough people
like appreciate where
you know if it may sound like you can't
you know get your
member of of congress or you know
something to do anything
um but there's certainly things like um
you know even another thing that
happened in this
this uh the pandemic was the mayor's for
guaranteed income launched and then
suddenly
that opened the avenue for people to
contact their mayors and encourage them
to
join this and launch it that's another
thing you can do right in addition to
the march you can
yell at your mayor be like hey why
aren't you part of mayors for a
guaranteed income
and the way that works is you know you
get mayors on board and then suddenly
that lends this idea more credence and
then also you've got like city councils
that are
that are looking at this you've got like
also yesterday was a big day too because
california passed the first bill for a
publicly funded like
ongoing guaranteed income uh program
which is
for foster youth and that too came from
a pilot
that started in santa clara county that
came from
um i'm a board for the fund for humanity
the jail board uh funder free humanity
and that was a pilot that was started
there which is this little pilot
for a small group of youth aging out of
the foster youth system
and that did so well and also it
happened during the pandemic california
looks at this rising popularity that
again came out of stockton
and they say well let's do this
statewide and like a permanent thing to
make sure that
that those aging out of the foster youth
system have a basic income for three
years
and now that's a real thing like that is
a thing now as of yesterday so again
it's just amazing to watch these how
something can be
you know small and grow over time one
pilot may seem like a small thing but it
can grow into much bigger things
and i think that over time we're going
to see this stuff get bigger and bigger
and all of that
lends more momentum to the whole thing
to get more people on board more
organizations on board
and then once you get those kind of
organizations then
they're putting pressure on the members
of congress that would usually not
listen to people
and now they feel they have to because
the ones who hold influence over
them are saying look you need to do this
and that's really how stuff gets done
so if someone comes to you and they just
want to find out more about universal
basic income
uh and then you say okay here are the
things you should do
so for you back in the day it was mana
for me it was raising the floor by andy
stern
is there like a starter you give them
like hey read this book
i mean certainly you are the internet's
library on this so
like i i refer people to scoutsands.com
but like what
what what do you yeah uh tell people to
do
like i mean that was the that was the
the reasoning that i even
started writing uh because it was like
this kind of a long map
project of i want to cover all of these
different
frequently asked questions i want to
cover these different angles
and put it all into one place and so i
have that faq
on my blog and i refer to people to that
a lot and i even
you know because i have various articles
for different
commonly asked questions then i just
share those a lot as ways to
um get people introduced to the idea
so yeah like that was instead of like
stopping or not doing anything
and and writing um a book like you know
i could have spent years or something
writing that
um i just wanted to get little pieces of
shareable content
out and um create almost like a table of
contents for
for your multiple normal questions that
are asked
and i think now at some point i'll i'll
hopefully transform that into a book
here in the immediate future
too to make that even easier but the
short answer to this god is you just say
like hey
uh read yang's book that could have been
you know you have to go through all of
this like that's good
that's that's a good intro too for sure
and also andy stern's book there's uh
and that's the thing too is there's a
there's just a great many books
that can um that can introduce people
in different ways um and
it's important to match that book with
them so you know maybe someone doesn't
care about the automation argument
maybe they care about you know the way
the welfare system works right now their
existing safe net i would say hey read
you know tyranny of kindness by theresa
finichiello
like uh that's like a great book to read
you know who's doing a sequel to that
book right now is annie lowery andy
lowry's apparently
deep in how the welfare system works um
so
uh really excited to see what she she
finds out i i like where you're going
with this this so this is an important
task thought
so what you have to do is you have to
say like well what kind of person a
reader are you and then be like if
you're this
read yang's book if you're this uh read
uh teresa's book if you're this like
that that's very interesting yeah
or listen to this podcast you know if
you're not a reader then listen to this
or if you prefer watching you know
documentaries and here's like a
documentary you got to watch first like
yeah it's all about meeting people where
they are and make sure that you know
they're able to consume
um something about basic income in a way
that they prefer
and that um reaches them based on you
know be their
liberal or conservative or libertarian
or green party or whatever
there's just so many different angles to
to get people to understand so people
want to support you scottsdales.com
um what do you see as like the next
couple of steps in the movement
uh and uh i'm so grateful to you man i
mean like uh going through this journey
with you i mean you've taught me a lot
uh i genuinely do like people are like
oh andrew yang's mr ubi and it's like
sort of
scott deserves that title more than i do
but
um but yeah like how would you recommend
that people best support the movement
yeah that's a that's a good question and
um
yeah i think number one key is
is first of all you know becoming more
educated
on the topic so you know just like my
own process was i didn't want to like
start speaking about it
or you know um writing about it doing
anything
when i didn't feel i knew enough about
it and so that
involved this educational process of
doing a lot
a lot of of reading and um
you know first so i always think that's
key is definitely
learn more about it so you can speak
about it because you don't want to it
just
it works so much better to be in a
conversation with someone and be able to
answer
all their questions instead of being
like i don't know i hadn't thought about
that
you know that kind of thing so education
important and another part is yeah
finding the the right thing for you um
being you know at least donating to
organizations is definitely very helpful
if you can't do that you know there's
there's just so many other things you
can
um you know write you can um
you know contact you can be like become
that person
my preferred method is just to open the
just to open the window and just start
yelling
some variant uh i you know i change what
i yell
i can scream uh you know uh
cash for all basic income give people
money i change it up based on the day
just open the window up and just yell
i'm mad as hell i'm not going to take
anymore without a basic income
[Music]
you